[Music]
people love celebrating crazy traditions
we found some pretty strange national
holidays that really exist and some of
them are downright absurd watch this
video and tell the n to find out about
the most delicious holiday ever new here
subscribe to the things channel to be
the first to see our newest videos and
click that thumbs up button to like this
video now check out the strangest
national holidays that really exist
national unicorn day unicorns have been
the most beloved mythological creature
since forever the ancient Greeks
believed that unicorns lived in the
faraway exotic lands of India in the
Middle Ages versions of the Bible had
passages about unicorns it symbolized
strength
purity and enchantment unicorns were
believed to be the pets of virgin women
there's even a sculpture at Warsaw's
National Museum of the Virgin Mary
holding a unicorn on her lap and petting
it unicorns have been the subject of
countless fairy tales and folk tales
some of the more famous literature
featuring unicorns are JK Rowling's
Harry Potter and the Sorcerer's Stone
Lewis Carroll's through the
looking-glass and the last bottle by CS
Lewis of course they should have their
own national day of celebration they say
unicorn day was created to celebrate
these magical creatures and remind
adults to enjoy the fun of fantasy again
kids museum to love this holiday and
invite kids to celebrate with unicorn
hunts unicorn mask making and the
unicorn stories if you didn't know about
this fun day mark your calendars for
next year
unicorn day was April 9th this year so
hold on to your wishes and get ready for
next year we kind of wish unicorn day
was every day of the year
Polar Bear Plunge day look be more fun
than stripping down to your undies and
hurling yourself into an ice-cold body
of water in the dead of winter well it
might not be for everyone the folks in
the northern hemisphere love it every
year on January 1st people runs with the
icy waters and dunk themselves in these
polar bear swims have been going on for
over a century the first ever recorded
plunge was in Boston in 1904 in Canada
the Polar Bear Plunge is somewhat of a
New Year's Day tradition
Vancouver's Polar Bear Swim day has been
going strong since 1920 and has 1,000 to
2,000 registered participants each year
to jump into the English Bay that's a
lot of shivering Canadians in the
Netherlands about 30,000 people hop into
the icy cold sea every year and that's
just the tip of the iceberg in the
United States 12,000 people do the
plunge to raise money for the Special
Olympics
so far they've collected millions of
dollars why do so many people do this
crazy cold plunge into the freezing
waters every year many say that after
you've done that you can tackle any
challenges the New Year has to offer put
a pillow on your fridge day you're
probably thinking we just made this one
up but it's a 100 percent real actual
holiday put a pillow on your fridge day
falls on May 29th and is celebrated in
Europe and the United States it stems
from an old tradition in the 1900s for
people for the liner or a piece of cloth
in their pantries for good luck the
piece of cloth was typically torn from
something that was kept in the bedroom
like a blanket or a nightgown families
believe placing a piece of cloth from
the bedroom into a place for food was
capped would bring plenty of food and
rich fertility in their lives when
refrigerators were invented back in the
1920s folks began putting pillows in
their fridge to carry on the tradition
apparently people still believe that
putting your pillow in your fridge on
May 29th will bring new prosperity and
good fortune for the rest of the year
there's even a Facebook page full of
pictures of people's fridges with
pillows on top or inside so lose the
pints of ice cream and hot pockets and
pop your pillow in the freezer or stick
it on top if you don't want it to smell
like grandma's lamb chops awkward
moments day have you ever embarrassed
yourself in class tripped over nothing
or did
something totally ridiculous in front of
your crush then March 18th is your day
national awkward moments day was created
for us to be able to laugh at ourselves
everyone has those moments where we wish
we could just disappear and hop into a
time machine so we can erase those
awkward moments there's even a hashtag
so people can post and share their
awkward moments with the world don't
believe us check out the hashtag awkward
moments day and you'll see we found a
couple of laugh out loud
offer moments like the guy who said you
thought his passing gas was going to be
on silent mode that wound up like a
nuclear bomb blast and there's the video
of the time where the first bomb meets a
high-five to funny on Twitter Chester
Tina posted a gift with a caption that
said when you're casually scrolling at
the zoo but suddenly run into your ex
awkward maybe you fell asleep at your
desk could gum in your mouth and woke up
to find it stuck in your veins because I
never happened over here alright it
totally did hashtag awkward moment stay
stick out your tongue day nobody knows
who came up with this silly holiday and
it lands on July 19th every year its
nationals stick out your tongue day on
this day people are encouraged to stick
out their tongues just make sure that
people use stick it out at know about
this crappy holiday or they might think
you're rude and you could be in for some
dirty looks
in fact many cultures find sticking your
tongue out rude and childish in Tibet
however sticking out your tongue is
considered a polite form of greeting
okay now all we can picture is a bunch
of Tibetan monks sticking their tongues
out of each other in honor of this
holiday here are some fun facts about
the time did you know the tongue is the
strongest muscle in the body it comes in
all different shapes and sizes all while
it's often taken for granted it's vital
for speech eating tasting and swallowing
the average person has about 10,000
taste buds which are located on and
under the tongue as well as on the
cheeks and roof of the mouth
some people believe your tongue can
reveal possible health issues so go
ahead and stick your tongue out
kid inventors day did you know that
January 17th is kid inventors day you
know this holiday doesn't fall under the
strange category but it is super cool
every year on this day kids get to
celebrate their creativity and new ideas
by showing off their latest inventions
January 17th isn't just a random date
it's the birthday of the famous
politician child inventor and all-around
genius Benjamin Franklin when Ben was
just a kid he invented the world's first
swim flippers who designed them to go in
the hands instead of the feet pretty
cool right he has served as an
inspiration for young fingers everywhere
did you know it was a child who invented
the language that the blind used for
reading all over the world known as
Braille its inventor young Lewis Braille
lost his vision at 3 years old
who spent his early teen years
developing the revolutionary language on
a school for the blind in Paris and he's
not the only amazing kid inventor nearly
200 years later an American teen named
Ryan Patterson's invented a glove with
special sensors that translates the hand
noises of sign language into written
words from a computer kids author
invented popsicles the trampoline and
the snowmobile impressive mark your
calendars kids what will you think of
next year Teddy Fair Day this might be
the cutest of strange national holidays
we found its national teddy bear day and
it falls on September 9th every year who
out there has a teddy bear they love
well this is the day to take your little
bear out into the world with you don't
be embarrassed it's national teddy bear
Day we could all use a coupla friend now
and then here's a bit of teddy bear
history for you in 1902
President Theodore Roosevelt also known
as Heidi Roosevelt went on a hunting
trip there was an injured bear cub in
the woods and Teddy refused to shoot it
the hunting trip made news it was even
depicted as a cartoon in The Washington
Post a candy store owner in New York by
the name of Morris victim had two
stuffed bears which were made by his
wife displayed in the store window after
he read about Teddy Roosevelt's hunting
trip he wrote a letter
president asking permission to name the
toys teddy bears and the rest is history
our stuffed friends were named after a
compassion president and should be
celebrated so on September 9th take your
teddy bear with you you can take
pictures and post them with the hashtag
national teddy bear Day Talk Like a
Pirate Day as you scallywags head out on
September 19th don't be surprised if you
hear people shouting things like ahoy
matey and hi captain
that's because September 19th is
international Talk Like a Pirate Day
whether you're a bilge rat or a beauty
you can take to the streets with your
peg legs and eye patches to greet your
fellow pirates with an empathetic AR and
people won't think you're a total weirdo
this holiday was created in 1995 when
John Bower who goes by old chum bucket
and it's good old friend Marc summers or
captain slappy started encouraging each
other on the racquetball court using
pirate slang it caught on
they began celebrating it every year
before they knew it
Talk Like a Pirate Day became an
international holiday once and tips on
how to talk like a pirate when you
answer the phone instead of saying hello
shop ahoy me hearties yeah instead of
saying check this out say a loss if you
forgot your homework just say me
treasure map was eaten by a little bit
of scurvy but you'll probably have to
walk the plank but at least you'll have
some fun
so grab your sword sea dogs and talk
like a pirate our national absurdity day
we probably experience a little
absurdity every day so why not make it a
holiday November 20th it's national
absurdity day absurdity refers to
anything strange illogical irrational
unreasonable or nonsensical the
absurdist movement in theatre and
literature came after world war ii
writers were so freaked out by the
threat of nuclear war they decided
nothing made sense anymore and portray
their stress and anxiety in absurd and
sometimes disturbing ways famous
absurdists include Samuel Beckett and
Harold Pinter Lewis
caroled alice in wonderland' is
considered one of the most famous pieces
of absurdist literature on national
absurdity day you have a free pass to go
nuts you can do fun crazy silly wackadoo
things without getting into too much
trouble just tell your parents it's
national absurdity day it's probably not
a coincidence that this holiday fall so
close to Thanksgiving we all experience
a little absurdity when we spend time
with our extended families of course
there is a hashtag for this one too so
if you decide to dress as a mouse
wearing a cat costume or wear four top
hats and a whistle while eating crackers
this is the day to do it just post it on
social media so we can all have a good
laugh eat ice cream for breakfast day
this is our favorite strange holiday by
far it's eat ice cream for breakfast day
although it falls on February 3rd we
think it should be celebrated every day
how did this glorious holiday start well
in the 1960s a women from New York named
Florence Rappaport had six kids who were
born on a frigid February morning she
said that it was cold and snowy and the
kids were complaining them it was too
cold to do anything so Florence said
let's have ice cream for breakfast the
kids cheered and a new family tradition
was born they had so much fun they
reminded her the following year and they
celebrated again thanks to Florence's
grandchildren who have traveled all over
the world eat ice cream for breakfast
day has become an international holiday
celebrated from Germany all the way to
Nepal these worldwide celebrations have
been featured in the Chinese edition of
Cosmopolitan magazine and an Israeli
newspaper too how do you celebrate this
delicious holiday it's easy just start
with two scoops or more of your favorite
ice cream you can get creative and add
it to pancakes or eat it by itself put a
cheerful way to enjoy a cold winter day
so which strange holiday is your
favorites tell us in the comments and
those are the strangest national
holidays that really exist thanks for
watching the things
next time
[Music]